hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my episode 6 Q&A video talk to y'all
about cold hands mad Queens and Eris
everybody wondering if Daenerys is
turning into the mad queen so just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet a lot of cold hands a
lot of Lady Stoneheart there was even
some euron greyjoy stuff that I didn't
mention in my Brienne video that George
our Martin released so I'll talk about
that at the end of this video it's
unrelated to what's happening on the TV
show right now other than Euron is a
villain in the story for Yara right now
but it seems like the books are gonna be
turning him into a villain on a much
bigger scale so here we go first
question tencel eggie asks didn't you
think it was kind of BS how Daenerys
needed exactly a thousand ships kind of
made me laugh at that scene yeah because
that's the exact number of ships that
you're on had the Yara stole so you'd
see where they're going with it it seems
like they're going to be helping
Daenerys out unless you're on can build
his ships faster and get there but I
don't think that even be possible this
is one of those examples of the show
fudging things just a little bit like
how could the faith militant Forge all
that new Kingsguard armor without Jamie
or Cersei finding out about it so there
are certain convenient things on the
show that you just have to try and look
through so when Yaron Theon took off
with your on ships it seemed like they
only had a couple hundred people but now
it's is that they're saying they had way
more ships than that so it doesn't
exactly make sense it doesn't totally
add up next question
boo sis Wei asks is drinking rabbit
blood a normal thing in these conditions
or is it supposed to be like Jojen paste
from the books well in that case I think
he's just drinking it for hydration and
because it's worn by the body of the
animal if you don't know what Jojen
paste is when bran was still underneath
the weirwood training with the
three-eyed raven lief would give him
this concoction to eat it was sustenance
but it also seemed like it had blood in
it as if it came from somewhere like
jochen's dead body so that's why people
were like maybe he's eating jochen's
body to make himself more powerful I
never really bought into that theory I
think it could be the blood of another
animal but I think the idea is is that
it's like the red sap from the weirwoods
because when you look here the weirwoods
are bleeding from their eyes or at least
it looks like they're bleeding from the
eyes on the faces that are carved here
that's just sap from the tree so the sap
looks like blood so I think that's
what's in the paste next question Sophie
asks do you think that Tommen will be
the faith
since champion for Circe's trial by
combat I'm not expecting that but it
would be a huge WTF the leading tinfoil
theory is that we're gonna wind up with
cleganebowl but there could be some
giant WTF twists where Tom and is forced
to fight I don't even know if there's
precedent for that I don't think a king
has ever been called to fight in trial
by combat himself usually if the King's
involved in a situation like this he's
choosing someone else to fight for him
but there's another big twist we could
see a seven-way trial by combat because
of the seven-pointed star if you've
never heard of it a seven-way trial by
combat is exactly like it sounds it's
seven-on-seven it's a big part of the
Dunkin egg series so we might end up
seeing that on the TV show but I think
we're really all hoping for a
cleganebowl next question Tobias asks
any chance for Lady Stoneheart
well george RR martin actually said at
the book convention this weekend that
they've cut her out of the show so i'm
assuming he's not lying
which means no ladies don't heart if you
don't know why everyone's asking about
ladies stone heart recently it's because
we're going to the Riverlands that's
where she shows up in the book so
everyone's like off we're gonna be
getting the Brotherhood without banners
coming back does that mean the lady's
stolen hearts coming so based on what
george RR martin says i'm assuming not
next question and miriam asks I think
that Kevin Lannister is up to something
he's stood by and let Tommen dismiss
Jaime from the Kingsguard sending him
off to Riverrun maybe because Lancel is
his son and he's very close to the high
Sparrow and the faith militants I think
that's definitely what's going on he's
just trying not to let things go
sideways he's actually he's trying to
help the kingdom he wants stability in
the kingdom and all this craziness is
happening in King's Landing so he
doesn't want to make things worse and he
wants his son back so being handed the
King he's kind of between a rock and a
hard place right now the rock being
Tommen's brain in the hard place being
the high Sparrow next question ethic is
asks so if Sansa is the head of House
Stark does that mean she's able to
legitimize Jon Snow so that he would
become Jon Stark no it had to become by
royal decree the only way they could get
around that is that they did the king in
the north type thing like where Robb
Stark declared himself king in the north
the only problem was something like that
is that even though the North might
support that they wouldn't in King's
Landing so if Sansa named herself queen
of the north named Jon Snow Jon Stark
and Jon were to try to do anything that
a noble Lord might do in hair
property marry into another great house
they might deny his claim but I don't
really think any that's gonna be an
issue just because there's gonna be a
couple more big reveals in the season
most of you probably know what I'm
talking about I'm talking about our joy
stuff so we'll have plenty more to talk
about with respect to jon snow's
multiple titles his growing list of
titles next question
Kass asks if you could ask George one
thing what would it be I assume you're
talking about George our Martin I would
actually ask him if he has a succession
plan if he were to pass away someday
what do you want people to continue Song
of Ice and Fire in the way that
Tolkien's heirs have continued the
talking novels it's not really a
question you can ask someone without
sounding like a dick hey listen you're
gonna die soon so is somebody else gonna
take over you don't really want to
confront someone you admire with their
own mortality but barring that I would
probably try to find some interesting
football question to ask him
football's like his other obsession in
addition to fantasy literature next
question Bobby asks did you know the
words burn them all were said during
brands flashback while the White Walkers
were on-screen and the Knights can't
grab brands arm is that confirmation
that will have White Walkers versus
dragons in the end well I think we all
kind of expected that anyway but that's
really the show connecting dots in that
we're probably going to have to burn all
the whites there was a lot of wild fire
in those flashbacks too so we could see
a situation where Daenerys or someone
else tries to blow up King's Landing
like blow up the red keep maybe that's
what makes it look like this in all of
Daenerys visions or if brands gonna try
and avoid some future outcome where it
gets blown up
maybe they'll try and use wildfire
against the Knights king's army either
way any kind of fire dragon fire
wildfire probably very effective against
whites
next question Nerine asks do you think
that Daenerys will become the mad queen
like her father as it seems like she's
become increasingly more bloodthirsty
than freedom thirsty I think that she's
definitely ready to go to Westeros so
that's why it seems like she's more
bloodthirsty and she's done trying to
bargain and she's ready to conquer but I
definitely think the show is turning her
into a villain when I say that it's just
making her seem like a villain right now
I think ultimately she'll have to work
with whoever's still alive when it's
time to fight the night's king's army he
hasn't made it south of the wall yet
there's a couple other big battles
happening we have the snow bowl it's
going to be happening towards the end of
this season
so they just want you to think that
Daenerys is gonna come in and try and
destroy Westeros let's make Westeros
great again by destroying it setting it
on fire tearing down all their castles
when you really think about what she's
saying like what is she expecting that
she's gonna live in is she gonna live
like a dothraki in a tent for the rest
of her life probably hasn't completely
thought this through but I think once
she meets some of the other big
characters she'll start to realize
what's going on but for now they're just
having a little bit of fun with Mad
Queen imagery but I don't think it's
gonna get as bad as the Mad King was
thank you so much for so many questions
though these are always a ton of fun to
do here's some cold hand stuff I know I
just wanted to clarify a little bit
George R Martin unfortunately didn't
specify anything between show hands and
the book cold hands so I think based on
what Leif says in the books just cold
hands being this ancient person she
actually says that he's very very old
that he's definitely not benjin in the
books but he is a brother of the Nights
Watch because he addresses Samwell as
brother that's probably because he used
to be a brother of the Nights Watch but
you're on Greyjoy's stuff I didn't know
if I'd have time to do a euron greyjoy
video later this week so the big stuff
that happened when George Martin was
reading from this new material from wins
a winner is that euron greyjoy straps
the damp hair to his ship makes him
drink a hallucinogen that gives him
visions and he sees Euron in a suit of
Valyrian armor on the Iron Throne with
someone that seems very white so it's
almost like he's seeing Euron become one
of the big villains of the series
alongside Daenerys but that's only one
potential future so I think they're just
making you crap your pants a little bit
thinking that you're on is going to
co-opt Daenerys and he's going to take
the Iron Throne but I do not think that
it's ultimately going to play out that
way even though there's gonna be a whole
bunch of big Joran stuff happening but
he has this really awesome shark teeth
crown that he wears when he's sitting on
the Iron Throne so it's just Martin
telling you that your on is gonna be a
total badass in wins a winner what's
gonna happen next is I'll be posting the
guardians of the galaxy to video there
was just a big announcement on the bill
and let me know if there's any specific
Game of Thrones bonus video you guys
want this week just let me know in the
comments there'll be at least one more
bonus video before my episode 7 video
and giveaway time congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner Tyler leach
you win a $20 Amazon gift card be sure
to private message me on the
back into my channel so I can get your
contact details that's just on the about
page so why you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for my
episode 6 video and you can click here
to learn about how Ramsay Bolton wants
to die on the show the actor who plays
Ramsay was just talking about how he
wants to die so thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight